the chief prosecutor of the
international criminal court is seeking
to open an investigation into the
philippine government's war on drugs
president rodrigo duterte's regime has
killed at least six thousand suspected
drug dealers
the icc claims this could amount to
crimes against
humanity the philippines is not a member
of the icc and duterte says that he will
not cooperate with the investigation
calling it politically motivated let's
get more we are joined by carlos conde
he is a senior philippines researcher at
the human rights watch
group and he joins us from manila
welcome to you carlos and thank you so
much for being on the program
talk with us a little bit more about the
war on drugs
in duterte's philippines
the war on drugs which started in 2016
when
the 30 became president has killed
thousands and thousands of filipinos
mostly poor filipinos across the
philippines and this has been
the one single human rights catastrophe
this country has ever seen
and so um you know hundreds and
thousands of families have been
suffering from the impact of the drug
war including children
and this has debilitated and devastated
their lives and so this
uh news today or last night about the
icc
requesting an investigation into these
killings is very definitely a welcome
news uh
for many of these uh victims of the drug
war and also
uh there's a lot of hope that this will
ultimately lead to accountability
how high can that hope possibly be
though carlos let me ask you because you
know as we've heard duterte says he
couldn't care less
about the court's investigation he's
also said that he will not
cooperate so realistically speaking how
far can the icc get
under those conditions you think
well uh the hope is that he this can get
as high as possible uh to the third
in fact in the request finding that uh
uh
prosecutor bensouda uh filed before the
icc pretrial pre-trial chamber
it was clear that he she uh made a
connection between
uh public officials police drug
officials and local government officials
who enforce
the the war on drugs to a connection to
the president himself so
uh i think the the icc uh investigators
are going to aim pretty high on this one
now
whether uh duterte will cooperate with
the uh
investigators um at this point actually
that does not
uh matter a lot a lot of these victims
because
he has said the same thing to uh uh the
special
rapporteur of the u.n on election
judicial killings and he has pretty much
um taken efforts to try to evade
accountability
uh but that this has not stopped the icc
from conducting its preliminary
examination and now it has not stopped
uh ex-prosecutor bensouda to request a
formal investigation where does the
public stand on all of this i'm just
curious because you know
duterte he he always defends his
crackdown claiming that he's only doing
what the people want him to do
well to a large degree uh the filipino
public still support him he's still
extremely popular
um his drug war policy if you talk to
people uh
his supporters are very very vocal about
supporting it so
i think uh the administration is
counting very much on this uh public
support but
on the other hand i think that this
decision by the icc
to really commence the process of
accountability
will uh hopefully that will swing some
uh uh perspectives toward uh toward
justice and toward accountability and to
really
uh force the government to end uh the
continuing
killings in the philippines uh related
to the drug war because even as we speak
the killings are still happening on
a regular basis and so i think that
this decision by the icc prosecutor will
help
convince uh some segment of the filipino
public to
to let accountability accountability
take its course
and it could amount to crimes against
humanity as the icc
attempts to get underway with this
investigation carlos conde senior
philippines researcher at human rights
watch thank you so much
you